[Musique]
sur les hauteurs des plateaux andins se
trouve l'origine d'un progrès majeurs
dans l'histoire de la médecine
l'arbuste quinquina et son écorce tout
on a isolé 200 un produit essentiel dans
la lutte contre la malaria la quinine
à l'époque les autochtones de la
cordillère des andes utilisent déjà
depuis longtemps
les corses de quinquina pour soigner
leur fièvre xviie siècle les jésuites
ont rapporté en europe où le remède est
rapidement devenu un traitement de choix
parmi les patients les plus célèbres le
roi louis xiv et sa cour
à l'époque la malaria mauvaise air en
italien est endémique
y compris dans les climats tempérés on
associe aux zones marécageuses ou malus
en latin d'où l'autre nom de la maladie
le paludisme au cours des décennies
suivantes
les corses de quinquina va être utilisé
non seulement comme traitement mais
aussi en prévention de la malaria en
1820 des chimistes joseph pennetier et
joseph bien aimé qu'avant tout en isole
l'ingrédient actif la quinine leurs
travaux vont permettre d'élaborer des
médicaments plus facile à administrer
avec des doses précises pour mieux
traiter les malades et ils sont nombreux
aux quatre coins du monde les
plantations de quinquina se multiplient
pour les soigner le produit se décline
en toutes sortes de boissons élixir et
autres tenues au goût amer distinctif à
la fin du 19e siècle on identifiera
enfin le parasite responsable de la
malaria le plasmodium transmis par des
moustiques
aujourd'hui malgré plusieurs avancées
cette maladie tue encore près de quatre
cent mille personnes par année de
nouveaux médicaments se sont ajoutés à
l'arsenal thérapeutique pour contourner
par exemple les résistances acquises par
le parasite depuis l'an dernier
un vaccin contre la malaria est
administré aux enfants de quelques pays
d'afrique
quant à la quinine avaient été remplacés
par des molécules synthétiques comme la
chloroquine enid roxy chloroquine ses
produits servent aussi à traiter
d'autres maladies pour certaines formes
d'arthrite et ils ont fait les
manchettes cette année comme traitement
potentiel contre lakovic 19 la quinine
elle n'a pas complètement disparu
on la retrouve encore dans une autre
sorte de remède l'eau pétillante et
délicieusement à maires de l'aude gym
tonique